Now, in order to understand how we obtain input from the user, it's best
represented in a simple analogy. Newspaper subscription. For instance,
newspapers are printed every day with a rich set of data that I don't have
access to unless I willingly subscribe to, or receive, that paper. Input
handling in HTML5 is a lot like that. In JavaScript we have the ability to
subscribe to this input data, such that when an event occurs, a block of code
will be called. To get started with this process you need to tell the browser
that you'd like to subscribe to a certain event such as On Click, On Mouse
Move, or On Key Down alongside what function you'd like to call when that event
happens. Let's take a look at the code. You can see here that we grab an
element from the dom named pLubbz, for life, and add an EventListener to it
from mousemove. What occurs is that when the mousemove event happens on the dom
object the onMouseMove function will be called where we've previously defined
onMouseMove before this declaration.